this video is sponsored by mobile
legends adventure
you know having finished the one piece
films i was almost certain that the
specials would be
easier to get through i mean surely
they'd be shorter right
well they're almost all two hours long
so
that's fun and so therefore 10 hours
worth of specials have been consumed in
order for me to present you with today's
video
jokes aside however there are some
really interesting elements to these
specials with one of my very favorites
coming up first for me to review however
i do want to also add that on december
31st i will finally be reviewing the
moral arc of dragon ball super so
look forward to that but in the meantime
i'm totally not mark and these are my
first impressions of thoughts on and
review for
the weird and wonderful world of one
pieces tv specials
i would like to take a moment to thank
mobile legends adventure for sponsoring
today's video
mobile legends adventure is a
stress-free free-to-play idol rpg for
adventurers with the game itself
including mysterious stories
dungeons mazes less complicated gameplay
and overall
a much more enjoyable experience and
it's available on the app store and
google play store
right now as someone that loves artwork
and animations something that
immediately caught my eye with this game
was their level of detail in their
character models and animations
it incorporates unique manga style with
attractive contours
dazzling battle effects with emphatic
animations alongside
expressive and detailed character models
personally my favorites are tigrill
because he was my main man from the
start
and carrie met because she looks like a
freaking god what's more is that this
game doesn't demand for you to always be
playing
i can get my rewards and train my heroes
even when i'm offline taking a much more
relaxed approach incorporating
stress-free idle gameplay
allowing me to earn tons of rewards
while playing casually providing for
those of you out there
me that don't have a lot of time the
option to set all the battles to
automatic so i can keep up with the
community and my friends while also
focusing on work or school what makes
this particular sponsorship even more
auspicious is that there's a christmas
campaign with special events and rewards
for adventurers unveiled on december
18th
so get your hands on these time limited
rewards and events waiting for you like
icy brawl which is a boss fight with a
friggin yeti and that's only the tip of
the iceberg when it comes to the content
that this game provides come and join
the adventure today and what's more is
when you download the game you can use
my unique code to receive
five premium summon scrolls so check out
the game for yourselves and i'll see you
there
links are in the description
3d2y with a runtime of 1 hour and 47
minutes 3d2y is a one-piece tv special
that aired in 2014 covering the events
following asus death
spoilers by the way the first 14 minutes
of this special recaps the events
leading up to the time skip in the manga
however unlike the manga itself this
ultimately covers what happened during a
small missing chunk
of that time while luffy was training
his new abilities right from the get-go
this is exactly the sort of material i
am looking for out of a tv special
to fill in some gaps within one piece's
already extensive timeline in a fun and
imaginative way
so right off the bat i am on board with
the direction of this special because of
this i can immediately identify where
this particular story is in the timeline
and where luffy's mindset currently is
and this special takes full advantage of
that i also enjoy that the focus of
luffy's training is to get stronger so
as to protect his friends
and through the natural means of
incorporating the boa hancock character
and her sisters it acts as a
surprisingly fitting substitute for
luffy's straw hat family in this regard
within this story he is essentially
fighting to save them
essentially and in a nutshell the
training that luffy undergoes within
this particular section of the story is
the impetus for this particular story's
narrative boa hancock still infatuated
by
luffy wants to make sure that he's
perfectly taken care of and so entrusts
her sisters and her subordinates in
giving luffy everything that she thinks
he needs including food
clothes and all sorts of stuff however
in the process of doing so they get
taken captive by the big bad of this
special mr world
and essentially the whole plot is then a
rescue mission on behalf of luffy and
boa in saving them from this big bad guy
with the big cannon what's more is that
characters like buggy the clowner used
to tremendous effect in this story also
to alleviate tension
and to focus on the comedic relief i've
always been a fan of buggy from his
design to his lying weasley personality
and this gimmick oda gave him of being a
warlord of the sea
with his adoring crew was a stroke of
genius in my opinion with that specific
dynamic being on full display in the
special in ways the manga i don't think
made full use of just yet though the
manga is still unfinished and let's be
honest
buggy is like a cockroach you could blow
up the entire world and he'd find some
way of coming back unscathed in various
scenes and fights during this particular
special his character is on full display
with comedy quick wit
and not so quick wit and honestly some
genuinely brave
moments on behalf of buggy also which
was honestly something i wasn't
expecting and what are the highlights
for me for sure there was also a fight
between boa hancock and this
old science lady that is
so unabashedly there purely for
fanservice i honestly don't know what to
say other than
it exists boa hancock gets kinda naked
and the old lady drinks this serum to
make her young and somehow makes her
clothes grow
and her glasses shrink moving on i think
this film does a fantastic job of not
just
including interesting characters but
also giving them reason to be there both
from a dramatic standpoint and a
narrative one
something i always found tiresome
regarding a lot of the older one-piece
films was that they would oftentimes
feel like singular isolated distractions
completely separate from the main plot
no ties to any past events in any
meaningful way
usually but this film gets it right in
my opinion
occupying a portion of the story that
was shown to us in the manga utilizing
characters we all love in meaningful
ways and
tying the villain once again to the
greater world and speaking of which
while i didn't find this bite in the
world guy all that interesting at first
as the special progressed during its run
time little breadcrumbs of information
were scattered throughout illuminating a
backstory
and a contrasting symmetry between this
villain and luffy both initially looking
to sail outwards into the sea in search
of their dreams with their brother
both losing their crew in the process
but the means by which their journeys
differ manifest as major factors in
creating the people they are today and
not to mention the tension they
experience with each other
culminating in a fight towards the end
of the special where this world
character
acts as the perfect antagonistic foil
for luffy at this point in his life
world values protecting his brother and
he judges luffy for not being enough to
protect his own
and he also has a mastery of the
different types of haki luffy has been
struggling to implement himself
this on top of the thematic elements of
this tale as well as the secondary
character dynamics now also at risk here
thanks to this world character it makes
this third act
captivating and enjoyable and not to
mention kinda tense even though this
film only covered on my new fraction of
the time luffy spend training
after the events of marineford as a
dragon ball fan that enjoys training
arcs
even getting a glimpse at that
progression is enough for me to whet my
appetite with one piece is a great
series but one aspect i would have liked
to have seen more of was how the
different characters came up with and
developed their techniques this film
gave me that or
at the very least an indication of what
happened
it's a very fun story with a strong
emotional core and what's more
is the animation is bonkers too check it
out if you haven't seen it i
highly recommend it adventure of
nebulandia adventure of nebulandia
is a one-piece tv special that aired
almost exactly five years ago to the day
i've praised different shows and films
for starting with a bang but
this one does that on acid the very
first scene shows the straw hats
arriving at a location before being
bombarded and attacked
showing footage of luffy dying
and when faced with this enormous army
of cgi marines how will the straw hats
contend with the three different
character models it has i'm serious
count them there's like three
jokes aside because of this opening
there's a large portion of the story
that is dedicated to a flashback which
means that to a degree there's an
element of dramatic irony
here we know where the story is going
but the characters don't and in this
case the tv special elected to swerve us
as well as the straw hats when the
climactic event actually does get
underway we think it's going one way but
it actually goes a different way unlike
the prior film which occupies a very
specific period of time during one piece
of story
this much like the rest of the films
arbitrarily and vaguely slots itself in
with
all the grace i would expect from a tv
special they're sailing past an island
and would you look who it is
it's foxy remember him
no well neither does luffy but boy is he
mad and dagnammit does he wants some
payback from that last time luffy gave
him the wham bam rubber man knockout oh
yeah
the foxy pirates in this film feels sort
of like a sideshow novelty act that
through flashbacks a few funny moments
and some clever placement of nostalgic
throwbacks
integrate themselves as the primary
antagonistic force within this narrative
early on
and they are sort of i'll explain you
see there's some difference with this
foxy crew compared to their days with
the davey back fight and that's the
addition of two new crewmates
dojaku an experienced shipwright and
komei
a former marine the plot early on
follows in the same spirit as the
original arc of long ring long land the
foxy pirates propose a rematch of their
davey back fight with the first round
being an eating competition
however thankfully the plot takes an
interesting turn away from where i
thought it was going as sanji luffy and
zoro all fall victim to the master plan
put in place by the two new recruits of
the foxy pirates double-crossing their
own crew
they now have the straw hats in place to
eat these mushrooms
that basically make them all weak and
unmotivated to be honest i thought this
was going to be a really bad special
focusing largely on the davy back fight
but it turned itself around in the first
act as it instead of being a rematch
with foxy
becomes an unexpected rescue mission
where the typically less combative
characters aside from frankie and robin
i guess have to now
save the rest of their crew it turns out
the two new recruits on the foxy pirates
are both marines supported by the world
government
specifically komei who he himself is a
vice admiral of the navy
essentially their plan is remove the
straw hats from the picture once and for
all there's some more surprises in this
special but i'll leave it there
in case anyone wants to check it out
because it's kind of good for those of
you that enjoy the world building there
are some cool elements here and there to
this one too
now with luffy sanji and zorro in tow
the vice admiral and his subordinates
take this cargo of prisoners to an
island called
nebulandia oh my god he said it he said
it
this island incorporates some really
cool stuff like a giant plant that eats
devil fruit folk but what i liked most
about this was the sea water mist that
envelops the area zapping everyone who
has devil fruit abilities of their
powers which i honestly really enjoyed
as it meant that luffy had to rely on
his friends more than he might
normally it's a rather simple mechanic
but it made an interesting difference to
the story seeing as it usually is
all the powers are none of the powers
along with no energy because the sea
water usually kills them or tries to
kill them at least
from an animation front i thought it
looked fairly standard with moments that
looked rather great and something i
thought was nice was how the film covers
many different color palettes
adding variety to the film though i'm
not personally a fan of the over
saturated color palettes that this film
bathes in additionally while i was happy
that the foxy pirates facilitated an
early swerve in the film
i wasn't a massive fan of their
participation throughout and to be
honest
thought someone else could have been
more fun to tag along with the straw hat
crew
overall i thought the film itself was
interesting in parts with some moments
that operated around some really cool
ideas and surprises the special itself
isn't amazing but it has more hits than
misses for me worth checking out if
you're a fan of the series
adventure in the ocean's navel while
sounding like an average nautical themed
adult fetish film
adventures in the ocean's navel is also
the title of the very first one-piece tv
special released in the year 2000 this
is thankfully only 49 minutes in length
and operates with a really simple story
there's a big hole in the ocean luffy
and co want to get the treasure inside
and that's pretty much the gist of this
one but
naturally things are a little more
complicated than they previously thought
once they get into this big ol hole this
entire special has a really nostalgic
vibe to it and one that i really really
liked
similar to the very first movie of the
one piece series i covered
it only has the east blue crew prior to
ever recruiting chopper or anyone else
thereafter
its animation is nostalgic humble and
quaint and it starts with luffy peeing
off the side of the ship
funny imagery aside however this begins
with a really characterful and funny set
of scenes
luffy is fishing for something big off
the side nami asks what he's doing and
then something big begins pulling the
ship
luffy thinking it's a massive catch
starts pulling everything and the ship
along to that destination while nami and
everyone wonder what the heck is going
on they finally reached the end and it's
a treasure chest luffy
immeasurably disappointed throws the
chest away citing that it tasted
awful prompting nami to then jump into
the water after it getting angry at
luffy for throwing it away
i loved this interaction because it only
works if you understand these characters
it's simple but it's entertaining
character writing it's compelling the
chest itself leads nami usa and sanji
down into the depths below in search of
a treasure
and just when i thought we were getting
away from this discovering a new island
trope in
every one of these standalone films what
do we get
in the depths of the ocean another
island
i actually really like the vibe in this
story it's easily the funniest out of
all of them that i've seen so far
has a great sense of exploration and
discovery while having a strong focus on
character
everything that happens in it happens as
a result of who these characters are how
do they find this location
luffy and nami being luffy and nami how
do they get down there luffy and usop
how do they survive and get discovered
sanji usaf and zaro all contributing in
their own unique way
that only makes sense if they do it this
is compelling writing 101 and while the
plot is simple
it very much is a story i can get behind
and enjoy
specifically because i'm a fan of the
series the second half of the story
however is a slightly more traditional
one-piece special in that they identify
a big bad and get to know the local
inhabitants and their struggles before
helping them thereafter they're scary
spooky skeleton zombie men pirates
talking bats and a plot involving this
young boy that's quite emotionally rich
too considering the time spent on the
actual topic
by the time i reached the end this felt
like all the best parts of thriller bark
meets the intro sequence of fishman
island crossed with indiana jones
it's fun the action isn't as strong as
the new more flashy films or specials
but the passion put into the writing for
this one is clear
it's a wonderful fun romp that isn't too
long and offers more bang for his buck
than most of these specials could even
hope to incorporate
i'm a huge fan of this one check it out
episode of sabo
if any of you out there someday decide
to tackle all of the one piece tv
specials like i did
you will no doubt come into contact
quite quickly with the likes of what i
call
the episode of series there are six one
piece tv specials affectionately titled
the episode of nami luffy the east blue
the mary's
skypia and in this case sabo every one
of these details previously told stories
in miniature
sort of like a speedrun of a particular
arc episode of nami details the ireland
park arc episode of skype and east blue
obviously cover their respective arcs
and episode of mary covers the water
seven
in these lobby arcs however episode of
luffy and episode of sabo while covering
previously released storylines like
luffy's origin and sabo's origin
and sabo's overall participation in the
dressrosa arc they also do so in tandem
with new material which is what i will
be doing today with episode of sabo i
won't be covering episode of luffy
simply because i'm exhausted and that
special was aggressively mediocre
however episode of sabo is at the very
least something i found enjoyable while
also shedding light once again on
pockets of time we weren't present for
with sabo
as he works his way up to revealing
himself to luffy at the coliseum in
dressrosa once again this is exactly
what i am looking for in a tv special
well sort of while 3d 2y was fantastic
in that it was almost entirely new
material
this does have a considerable chunk of
time dedicated to showing material we've
already seen
and so from the get-go i should say i
won't be covering the stuff that we've
seen already in the dressrosa video i
did for the manga
if you want to see those takes go check
out those videos myself my editor worked
very hard on them
but back to this special right out the
gate in the very first scene it
demonstrates exactly why i like tv
specials as a concept
they offer a long-running series the
possibility of expanding upon different
scenes while also demonstrating
different points of view i drew
attention to a particular cover chapter
that oda drew depicting ace and
whitebeard's graves ages ago
however what i didn't notice upon first
glancing it was that there were three
sake cups set alongside ace's grave a
clear indication that saba was
in fact alive before he was ever
revealed to be so in this special we
finally get to see him place those sake
cups
something we didn't get to actually see
in the original anime or
manga and while this special does at
large deal around the same story as
dressrosa
it more importantly predominantly shows
it from a new perspective
in sabo in the original material we
first came into contact with sabo proper
when he revealed himself to luffy during
the tournament
however in this we see not only sabo but
also koala
as they exchange information covertly at
a cafe in the city this acts as a useful
vehicle to remind viewers of the current
stakes and context going on in the
special in a natural way
illuminating to us also the very instant
sabo learns about the first place prize
of the tournament
aces flame flame fruit and throughout
this while luffy and the rest of the
pieces get put into place
it's interesting getting to witness
savo's takes on each of the goings-on
leading up to his grand reveal
short as they may be as a fan of the
series i quite enjoyed seeing them
as far as animation goes i found this
film to be surprisingly weak
while the artwork was perfectly fine and
good the animation felt very limited and
clunky
with the vast majority of it barely
moving at all relying heavily on stills
and limited animation i don't think this
would bother many heck i don't think the
vast majority of people out there would
even notice without someone pointing it
out to them if they weren't into
animation in the first place but if you
are someone who enjoys great animation
as a cornerstone to your animated media
maybe sit this one out to cap off this
special there's the moment sabo acquires
the flame flame fruit with additional
dialogue and reflection on what this
means to him
before blasting the floor saving rebecca
and winning the tournament ending
the special overall while i really
didn't love this special by any means i
can at least appreciate the angle with
which it chose to deliver its story
there wasn't a ton of extra stuff added
but what little there was i did enjoy
i don't think i'd recommend this one
over the original series or even as
supplementary material to most
it's really not necessary however if you
love one piece and are looking for
something to tie you over until the next
chapter releases
maybe check it out you could enjoy it
one piece heart of gold
this film starts out pretty much by the
books and the plot itself is really
simple overall there's a little girl of
value on the marine ship
and these pirates want her the pirates
themselves that want this child make up
the villains of the story and while
trying to capture the girls she uses the
chaos that ensues around her capture as
an opportunity to escape
and by pure chance in the vast expanse
of the ocean
who does she run into but the straw hat
crew
that convenient trope aside i do
actually really enjoy this little girl
character she's a little abrasive but
she's tough and that's something a
little different than what i usually see
in these films usually it's nami or
something that needs saving the villain
in this instance is probably the least
interesting villain i've come across in
any of these specials his name is
literally and i quote
mad treasure and he is a treasure hunter
specifically trying to get a hold of
this little girl because she knows where
the pure gold substance is
in this story pure gold is a substance
that can apparently by the entire world
[Laughter]
one major difference i noticed between
these specials is the quality of
animation
implemented and the stories they tell
apart from 3d 2y which was very good and
interesting all of the other specials
are animated in a much more limited
fashion than pretty much any of the
films available for viewing once again
the artwork and character likeness is
perfectly accurate but the movement is
very limited and very little character
acting you don't even need to compare
this to stellar animated features like
movie 6
or any of the modern ones either for
this to be obvious it's clear that the
time dedicated to these wasn't on par
with the films which i suppose is
perfectly fine i guess
films are supposed to be on a larger
scale anyway one thing i will say
regarding the film's approach in terms
of animation is that at the very end of
the film the quality does pick up quite
a bit
thankfully in addition to that the
selection of scenes and settings this
special boasts are interesting too
with a large chunk of this special
taking place in the belly of a giant
anglerfish and in saying that there's
some nice imagery with the giant angler
fish at the end
as well as some nice backgrounds across
the special overall from a story
standpoint
it might be because i've now sat through
so so many
tv specials and films that i've become
jaded of all of these recycled plot
lines
but the story didn't exactly set my
world on fire it has a lot of the same
bells and whistles used in almost any of
the other one-piece films or specials
contrived beginning that hooks the crew
with the main character or villain of
interest
they look for treasure get kidnapped
fight the bad guy at the end and repeat
and while that's a very basic outline a
lot of these specials didn't offer much
in the way of anything significant
branching out from this either
and specifically when it came to these
specials when i don't have really nice
animation to carry me through the film's
unimaginative story
i tend to look more harshly upon it
though i suppose that's my own failing
with that said i genuinely thought that
there were plenty of things
to enjoy about this one and it had at
the very least some interesting
backgrounds and a scrappy kid character
that turned out to be 200 years old
however
having gone through the last month
watching the films and now these tv
specials
i can safely say that they were
significantly better than i anticipated
them to be
now that's not to say that i thought
they were oscar-worthy though i really
did like movie six
i am very impressed nevertheless with
the level of consistency one piece's
back catalog of non-canon material
really has to offer
i was fully prepared to be much more
combative and harsh with my essays but
really none of the films were so bad to
warrant such a criticism and the vast
majority i even enjoyed to a great
extent
the last time i went through a back
catalogue of a particular anime's films
and specials
was dragon ball and i had significantly
more criticisms than i had for these
and speaking of dragon ball i will be
taking a break next thursday for the
christmas or
holiday break and my next video will be
out on december 31st
and on that day i will be dropping my
long-awaited review of the morrow
arc of dragon ball super i've been
waiting to talk about this and many of
you have been waiting some time for it
but until then that'll do it for this
week's video
i've been toying that mark i'll see you
all december 31st
and thank you all so much for watching
merry christmas
happy hanukkah happy kwanzaa or whatever
you choose to celebrate
i'll see you all right before the end of
the year